we have sound we're on time
nice to see you
nice to be here um
so today we're going to talk about
cookies and why we are returning
authentication cookies or the formal
title is probably better use introducing
bff back in for front and pattern
uh but i prefer return of the
authentication cookie
so i'm anders i've been working with the
login buttons if you want to say that
for
[Music]
about a decade
i've been focusing on that nowadays i
work with run the software and identity
server doing training speaking
consulting et cetera
i also have a background doing saml 2
which is
the short version 7.2 is a protocol you
shouldn't use
that's my notion of having spent 10
years learning it
deeply
so
but today the focus is on singular page
applications and authentication cookies
and session management
if we start from the beginning
where the web
uh the early days of the web the really
early days we had this pop-up coming up
asking for username and password and we
were doing basic authentication
but then fairly quickly we moved along
to the username and password being
entered on the web page
and we had a button login where we
posted the
username and password to the server the
server had some
action some stuff where it processed
this and validated the username and
password according to all security best
practices
and it's done
and then http is a stateless protocol
so what happens when our browser makes
the next request
if we just validated that on the server
side the next request that comes in the
web server is like who are you who did
you find me
so what did we do i have a special prize
for anyone who can tell me what we give
the
the web server to make it happy
cookies okay who was the first one
i think
here cookies here you go some cookies
for you
exactly
and then the web server is happy
uh are you equally happy looking like
that
uh great
uh
so
back then you know we already had this
cookie consent screens built into the
browser
and then everybody deactivated them
because there were so many cookies
and things were fine
we had our server side rendered html
pages every server-side processing all
worked well and nice
and then one day maybe 2004 five six
i don't remember exactly
i went to swedish map service
and was astonished it was possible to
pan and zoom
on the page without reloading the page
it was smooth it was client-side
what was the secret well the secret was
xml http request or ajax
of course it wasn't xml
do you know why it's named xml http
request
thing is that
if you
create some modern piece of technology
now and want management buy-in or
investors or anything you need to put in
ai machine learning and
blockchain technology
if you don't have those three
there will not be no management approval
for the technology
this was back in the xml age
they had to tack on xml just to get xml
approval and also the actual code was
done by the mx ms xml team from the
start
so it's just a marketing
thing
and we were happy we were doing
um
we were doing a lot of
nicely looking applications with the new
powers of the client side libraries
being able to do full
requests and we were creating really
recreating client server with the web
browser as being the client and
everything was nice
so one day in these nice times
i was sitting late at night at home
reading some web forum and found a
security researcher on that firm asking
do i know anyone who has one of these
modems
this was a fairly mode
common ads
modem in sweden there were like 200 or
300 000 out there
and i said yes i have and then i got a
private message from that security
researcher say hey nice
i've got i've created a web page here
can you please try to visit this webpage
and i was like uh sorry
first of all i shouldn't mention that we
on on this uh modem we had a setting
with uh dns settings where we could set
up
primary secondary and it just saved some
action when we wanted to change it so
i said
that yes i have this modem and he send
along the address to his web page
he said do you want to visit this one
and i said like
okay what do you think i did
of course i checked the website
who wouldn't
and i came to page with kittens
literally he had made a page with a
picture of kittens not exactly these
kittens but there were kittens
and that was ah okay it's safe
and then i started to think about it
okay wait wait wait a little he made a
post on a security forum asking for
people having specific kind of modem he
sent me private message
he
also said that please do not tell anyone
before i've published this and then he
wanted me to check a url so i checked
the page source
thing is these are not nice kittens
these are evil kittens because they come
with a hidden iframe
that
submitted
a form automatically to my modem
changing the dns servers on my home
network and it did this because of
course the cookie was sent along
because the authentication cookie
was at these times sent
based on the target only
so it didn't matter who the origin was
and the flawed security model here was i
mean i was thinking i was secure i was
sitting on my home network
these
pages were only uh available from the
internal my home internal network i mean
how could the evil kittens out on the
internet attack my modem it shouldn't be
possible but well it is with the
cross-site request forgery attack
because the evil kittens make my browser
render that page my computer makes the
request to the modem
and
with
this were these were also the days
before https was used everywhere
so
with
the security researcher controlling my
dns on my entire home network i started
these funny things on when visiting
newspaper sites because he had hijacked
them and filtered them etc
uh eventually he ended up getting this
published
on the real paper print of the may one
of the major swedish newspapers so it
was a great
really great research job
um
it was not so great for the most
bloggers who had to close down 200 000
customers
configuration options
so what do we do to
so what we've learned now
is that cookies on the one hand are
convenient because
they are simple or sorry they are
delicious they are
sorry i'm bad for your health if you eat
too many
they are simple because they are all
transmitted
with every request they're transmitted
but they're also bad because they're
order transmitted
so due to cross-search quest forgery we
had to do something else
what did we go for instead of
not cookies
what did we pick up instead
let's switch to for authentication
yes
generating a seat sort of token or even
switching to tokens altogether so is
this tokens
we can say so
um
so
uh yeah the liberator deliberately
transmitted tokens and when we had to
create a token why not use that for
authentication all the way
and then the oauth 2 implicit flow was
born
those earth 2 implicit flow is a way for
the single page application to get hold
of a token that it can then send off
with every api request
so what it did
is that the single page application
requested token
the token is attached on the query
string on a callback on the redirect
back
and
the client stores and manages them
secure as securely as it can in a
browser and then attaches to any
outbound calls
this approach has a number of drawbacks
one is that
a url is usually logged
or ends up in browser history etc we do
not want our sensitive tokens being
stored anywhere
referrer headers
this also has no protection against
token injection attacks where we want to
really uh force someone to log in as
someone else
this is a clause of attack where that is
reasonable
uh i mean if you haven't say what can
say sensitive data online therapy site
if you're doing online therapy you have
an online therapy site where you enter
your inner thoughts and save them
what if i can make you save them to my
account
so i can go read your data because you
save them to
save your date important data to my
account so we need to consider both the
case that i do i do not want someone
else to log into my account but i also
want to be sure i am logged into my
account and not someone else's account
when i do save sensitive data
this flow has no
protection against that
so we went further with the
authorization code flow with proof key
code exchange which is better
uh we are now making the front channel
call the redirect back forth we get
something called an authorization code
back representing the authorization
event and then we exchange that over
back channel for
uh the actual tokens we store and manage
the tokens
so this sold
the pixie flow or authorization code
flow with pixel is really great it
solves the security issues it is what we
are still using on server side
so it handles the
token exchange and handshake but what it
doesn't handle is token storage i mean
the browser is it a secured computing
environment
we have cross-site scripting we have bo
rogue plugins etc
i had great plugin to chrome it was a
plugin that allowed you to screen dump
and create a screen up of the entire
page not just the visible area do anyone
remember this
and then a rogue person
bought that tool and
injected spyware in a widely deployed
plugin that had had privileges to read
page contents on every single page
uh so that's why we do not trust the
browser so let's have a look what do we
do on the server-side application that
we can trust a bit more a server
well it request tokens
uh sorry i should say here so what we do
here to handle that the remedy is really
on the client side that
we are making the tokens extremely
short-lived like five minutes and every
five minutes we need to renew them by a
silent renew mechanism
which means that if someone manages to
steal the token
it is just valid for a few minutes after
that it's expired and we're fine
um
and then we need to renew that so what
do we do on the server side on the
server side we do the same dance we
request tokens we get back two tokens
the yellow access token and the blue
refresh token
we store them on the server side
we use the access token to call apis
the access token is still short-lived
because we are sending it on the wire to
in every api we are accessing
so with something being widespread
and it is also self-contained token
meaning that anyone that get hold of
this
can just use it there is no way to
revoke an access token once it's in the
wild
there should still be short-lived
and then we want a way for the server
when this is expired to get a new token
and that's where the refresh token is
used the refresh token
the server calls the
authorization service
with the refresh token
and asks for a new access token that it
can then use in subsequent calls
and this way the user do not have to
re-log in every five minutes that would
be kind of awkward wouldn't it
so this is great
but what about
client-side applications can we use the
same approach for
a single page application in a good way
well we could there are people doing it
but we still have the issue of storing
and managed tokens
the server side application is running
on the server in our data center under
our control is a secure environment to
store the tokens
while
in the browser not so much
so what did we do for browsers
well um the idea was
was simple
if we have a single page application
would render a small hidden iframe
this small hidden iframe
renders a page from the authorization
server where it sets uh
request tokens with prompt equal none
setting meaning that this should just
reuse the existing session don't show
any ui i mean a ui in the hidden iframe
wouldn't be visible
but as long as we have an ongoing asylum
session it works how is that session
represented how does the authorization
server that know that there is actually
a session going on
what is center line
cookie who was
uh i heard it from you remember the
first one
so sorry i i need to check now we are in
modern times do you consent to the
cookies
okay here you are
uh
so while this was happening
we also had another thing happening on
the same time
and that was
you remember the kittens
um
why don't we do a demo first before we
show the kittens uh let's do a demo on
how this works with a hidden iframe so i
have whipped up an excellent
web application to show off my html
design skills
you have high expectations now don't you
okay
i have a demo here i don't need the
mouse to be able to scroll um
so if i click here login
i'm redirected to the identity server
where i can now log in as alice alice
and i'm back
i can call apis
and i can log out i can even call some
of the apis are callable publicly but
tomorrow's forecaster is only for
logged in users
um if i log in again
now sorry
[Music]
on this
particular host
i have you remember we said we should
have short lived tokens so five minutes
is a reasonable relapse scenario
my identity server is ten seconds
uh so when i try to call the api again
it doesn't work but i can renew the
token silently and then
it works usually this renew token
happens in the background but then i
wouldn't be able to demo that it didn't
work so let's look at what we have here
in the browser dev tools
elements
when i press renew token
renew token do you see here it flashes
by that hidden small iframe is quickly
appearing and
removed
there's also another neat thing done
with this
and that is log out
there is a hidden iframe all the time
that
checks that the session is still
available on the server so
this is like magic
if i click here and click log out
yes i want to logout
i didn't click on the left side
it automatically detects i'm logged out
within a few seconds
and this is great this is about the best
user experience that can happen
that we can have
until
do you know about safari i don't have
safari so i have to
run with chrome but i'm using this block
third-party cookies
safari has it by default
and
chrome is they've said they want to
block it next year
but the thing is that
third-party cookies are really used for
two things one is uh authentication
distributed authentication and one is
tracking people for all uh
for advertisement and ad networks
so apple they care about privacy they
make their money off selling stuff
selling hardware google
cares kind of about privacy and they
make their money off internet ads
so they need to find a way to
block cookies for privacy without
breaking the revenue stream
but let's see if we go to the same do
the same
run the same application here i click
login
i'll login as alice i'm logging in as
alice i'm happy and
i'm signed out
i signed in didn't i
let's try again
silent sign in just focus by what
happened
okay browser devtools to the rescue
network
login
and we can see a number of things
happening what i want to
show you is this one check session
so let's go to
this one
which is the non
in privacy mode this is the one where
cross domain cookies are allowed
if i go to the call to check session
i can see that the identity service
session cookie is sent along in the
hidden iframe
and that is how the hidden iframe
detects that we have a session as long
as that cookie is there it detects we
have a session when the cookie is gone
it means we signed out and it
indicates back to the hosting
application that we are now on that
signed out
let's see here check session do you see
the cookie it's small but i don't see
the cookie
thing is that cookie was blocked because
it's a third-party request
so this elegant user experience we had
that is so nice is simply broken for
good
by
the browser vendors
and this isn't a question about a bug or
something we can fix in the library the
entire mechanisms that the open id
connect session management spec
is built around those mechanisms are
gone or broken we need to do something
else
so
in the meantime while this happened
things were also
changed other things were also changing
in the browser
uh and now let's see if i can get back
to extend
mode
and
let's slide show that sorry two
got this
yeah
so remember the evil kittens
during the crossout record
cross site request forgery attack on my
modem
that was happening because of the cookie
but
before the browsers implemented these
cookie limitations they also implemented
something else same site mode cookies so
previously the kittens rely on the fact
that the cookie is submitted solely on
based on the destination
uh addresses uh the the browser doesn't
validate that the is the kitten sending
the cookie and not me having loaded the
real settings form of the modem
with same size strict that has changed
the cook is now long no longer sent
and looking at browser support we can
see that
it since it looks okay
the colors are not that good but the
darkest thing is is green
these are really the
roses that are important
all the browsers that are the major ones
support same size mode cookies
for current and previous
and the recent versions
based on this the oauth 2 consortium
came out with new recommendations on how
to do
i was 2 in the browser
for simple architectures something start
from the same domain
use a cookie
instead
so the oauth 2 best practice for
browser-based
apps is to don't do oils 2 use a cookie
instead
and they even have some ascii art in the
spec on how to set this up
this is from the rfc isn't it brilliant
where it says that the browser should
interact with the
application server and then there is a
redirect to the authorization endpoint
of course because the browser should
display the login prompt on the
login server but after that all
interaction takes place through the
application server
and this is described as the backend for
end or bff pattern
where we keep the tokens outside of the
javascript
out of reach for javascript
to implement this we need the bff host a
bff host needs a bunch of components it
needs an open id connect client library
i know where we have one
in asp.net core we have add open id
connect the built-in library
we need a session management tool well i
know where we have one we have the
cookie
the cookie
handling for session management in
asp.net core
we do need
token management
we need to have renewable tokens storage
of tokens attaching tokens to outbound
calls etc
the open source identity model package
can do that
we need local and remote api endpoints i
mean that's a normal web api isn't it
and
for
remote endpoints we can use the yarp
proxy to send off calls to remote host
and we need some ui assets i mean that
can just be served out with static files
we need those
so these are the components that that
can be used and that you can use to
build a
back-end for front-end patent using
asp.net core tooling
at dwende we already did this
and it's part of our
identity server licensing packages
so
i want to show you a bit how this is how
we use this
and also a demo and i want to convert my
application to be using bff
so i'll go quickly through just the part
of what we will need to do on our back
end our back and we'll need to
add open a d connect setup
we will get two new end points login the
logout where we simply can redirect the
user when we want to link in and logout
we will need
some
session handling with same site strict
we can now set
we'll get a new endpoint on the get bff
user where we can get the currently
logged in user information about that
and we can
the problem here is when we set up the
session to use sliding expiration it
means that
the slightly expiration notion of that
is that
if i leave the computer
and i'm not active my site should be
logged out right
um
and that is done by the cookie being
valid for like 30 minutes or one hour
and
after half that time if i make a request
a new cookie is issued so i get another
hour
and that works nice
but
if i want to check from the client side
if the user is
signed out
i need to
make requests and i do not want my
automatic request to check if i am
signed in to actually
slide the session that would be quite
awkward so we added a
parameter slide equals false that you
can add to this endpoint to indicate
that
this request should not slide the
session this request is actually
something we want to use to check if the
session is expired
we also have support for back channel
logout notifications
and this really is the future
even for server-side applications the
front-channel log-out mechanism relies
on hidden iframes
so
if we can make a log-in work on
server-side applications with cookies
despite the cookie limitations but we
cannot make look out work smoothly
because that also relies on hidden
iframes
um
so what we have is a lo
is the bff component offers a local api
endpoint
that's also important
if you are are developing a single page
application we have this idea that we
have generic single page applications
calling generic apis and we have a bunch
of apis over here and our simple guild
page applications call all of those apis
equally and the apis are totally
independent of and provide generic
functionality
uh
that our applications can call is it
that way in the real world no
half of those apis at least half
are application specific
because we need we are just using that
functionality for on one specific
application right
so why do not simply implement those
apis on the local bff
and not defer it further
so um
i think i have another how do they be
the this call being authenticated
cookies who want more cookies
of course
do you consent to the cookies
okay good
uh yeah cookies
um
are you protecting your cookies from the
evil kittens
did you verify that your cookies are
same site
you sent it to them yes of course but if
they are not same-sized strict cookies
the kittens can steal them
the problem here is that this gentleman
may not have read the swedish list of
um
of ingredients yet to verify that it's
same size strict and people may not have
up-to-date browsers
there are people running old browsers
without same-sized support
that could still be vulnerable so in the
twende component we added
a simple cross site request for header x
csrf colon one
okay is that secure
it actually is
because the evil kittens
they are prohibited by course policy to
make direct api requests to the bff the
bff do not have a course policy allowing
third-party domains to make javascript
api requests the only thing the evil
kittens can do is to
render a hidden iframe that posts
something to our bff
and when we have a normal form post we
cannot attach
headers to it
we cannot
add headers
so if
the header is present we can know that
this came from a javascript and thanks
to course we can know that then it must
be a same domain request
so that's enough
and then we of course have the remote
apis remember where i said roughly half
of the apis are application specific the
other half
they get proxied through to the actual
api producer
and during that proxy
processing of the request
the
the relevant access token is attached
for us we do not have to do that
ourselves
so let's see if we can we have
a bit more than 20 we have like 27
minutes right
let's see if we can make this conversion
um so i need to just tell you a bit more
about the config
we also set up use endpoints this is how
we configure this
in the setup we have map
map controllers we map our local apis we
map
up login logout user the management vff
internal endpoints and
we map the remote api endpoints
so back to some code
and i have my running example here
and that is still not displaying there
we duplicate it
so now i'm happy i could of course have
served my
uh i mean i could have
must here um close all about this close
i could have served my spa from
cdn
the content delivery network
but i'm lucky i created a very very
small asp.net core web application that
serves my spa single-player application
so i already have an asp.net core
environment that where i can add the
stuff needed for the bff
the first thing we want to do is we need
to
set up so that we have authentication
server side authentication builder dot
services dot add authentication
we need to add
the cookie
let's call the scheme cookie and we want
cookie dot
same site equal same side mode strict
that's good
then let's add
add open
okay i need some new get packages
and i cheated a bit so they are
commented out in my project file
i'm adding the defender bff to under bff
europe and microsoft asp.net core
authentication open id connect packages
dot add open id connect
let's call it odc the scheme
uh
authority
now we want to move
these settings that we already have in
the single page application
we want to move those over to the
[Music]
uh to the server side application so the
authority is there opt dot authority no
dot
authority equals http
other host 5010
client id we can still use the same spa
um
we can no off.client id
uh
and the semicolons in here um we need
now when we do this
and move to server side we can have a
server-side secret
i make this somewhat smaller can you
still see at the back okay
um
opt dot response
type we want the code flow op dot
response mode
we want
restring response mode
we want to say that we should be able to
call an api we want to say that we
get a refresh token
uh and for historical acts reasons
that's called offline access
and we want to have get claims from
using for endpoint true
we want to save the incoming tokens
that's a good idea we want to map
inbound claims through this means
mapping bank claims this is my favorite
settings you know that
i was
ranting about the xmlh
so the identity at microsoft is is
anyone from the microsoft identity in
the team in the room
no good okay the identity with microsoft
are stuck in xmlh
they think that we want our claims to be
this long http column
xml schema so for
i want a simple name
in openid connect in the incoming tokens
the names are short nice and simple
so if we set map invite claims to false
we say keep our short simple nice names
don't mess them up
when we do that we also unfortunately
need to set up some token validation
parameters
because the token validation parameters
still
by default look at the awkward xml names
so now we need to tell the token
validation parameters that the name
claim type is name
and the role claim type is role and
nothing else thank you
finally we need to tell this that if we
are signing out
the sign out scheme
that we should call
if there is an incoming sign out request
is cookie
speaking of that we need to set up the
wire up schemes authentication schemes
correctly or two
we have opt default authenticate
default scheme
the default scheme is what we are using
to keep to the main session of the
application
when we want to log in that is in
authentication service lingo called
challenge
so this scheme when we want to sign in
we want to do that using the
using the oidc scheme
and we
need to set we can set the default sinus
scheme to
uh
should be odc as well
to work
so we've set up that
we need more services we need builder
services dot add authorization
we
need builder
services dot add
bff
and we want to add the remote apis
as well and that one is in another
namespace
ah done
that's all the services now let's set up
the pipeline um
you know we are always serving static
files first because we do not want to
fiddle around with authentication and
that overhead when we just want to
return a javascript asset
so let's leave this first and then
app.use routing
we want to app.use authentication then
the bff should go in between here
before app.use authorization
and finally we are defining our
endpoints use endpoints
and points
we want to map the
bff
management endpoints to get slash bfs
login bff logout
we want to map uh
map remote bff api endpoint so whenever
we make a request to anything under
slash api
on on the bff host
those calls should just be forwarded
right away to localhost 5002
where i am running my api
please note i had two apis the goals and
the weather api that i could call those
two strings
came from two different apis
and
i do not have to specify them here
i specify the root path so the b when we
alter our api
we can do that on the api host and we
can alter our javascript to call the new
apis but we do not have to change an
update and maintain an api list on our
bff
but this is a lightweight component from
an antenna's
point of view
[Music]
so that's it
that's all we have to do on the
uh
on the host
let's go to this spa and this is the
funny part
let's go here first we have a callback
html that was used as its target when
reader coming back from the identity in
the redirect do we need that anymore no
uh do i have to create a similar one in
the bff
no
because the authentication middleware
and authentication handlers have those
endpoints built in
so using oedc on the server side is much
less ceremony and doing it on the client
side
um do i need the odc client anymore no
do i need the silent renew page no
do i need the sites dot js yes please
my index
i
now we're moving the token handling to
the server side
remove the renew token and remove that
one or what you see
site.js what do we have inside.js
well the token renew button can go all
the open id connect settings can go
that's nice
i just found out
remember i have one thing i need to do
too
the
settings on the identity server somewhat
different
i need to update the identity server
with the new urls we now have a client
secret we want to allow refresh tokens
i'm just updating that enter the same
settings
so back to this poll i have no user
manager
i have this check if we are signed in so
let's go and have a look would define a
global variable is this a good idea with
a global variable
nope is this a demo where i can just be
lazy yes
uh
i want to call an api called bff slash
user on on page load
where i can check the result
and if the result equals a 1
it means we are not signed in if
the result equals
something else we are signed in so then
i can get this one so when we're not
signed in what happens is that the login
button is displayed
when we are signed in
in the similar way
a similar way the
log out button is displayed the renew
button is no longer there and then we
have this welcome text that is a bit
more complex
because we do not get a user object
right way i need to actually parse it
from result so
json.parse the result we parse it
and then use a profile name this is a
what we get back here is an array
so i can go to the array and check user
dot find
find and we have an element
if e dot type equals name
remember that i said don't use xml names
i would have been more
saving me a lot of keystrokes here right
um
so we can clear the old login detection
login previously called the odc client
user manager to sign in
now it's very simple window.location
equal
bff slash login right
log out is a bit more complex because
the log out endpoint requires a session
id to be sent and that is another c surf
protection
so i need to actually go and find it uh
window location is in user find e sorry
element
e dot type equals bff column
log
out url
dot value
the call apis is also simplified i mean
the previous version of the call apis
had to
called get user and then um
sorry it's called aps this is
this call api the call to call an api
preview they had to get user and then
set the request header with the
current access token
i can do that much easier now i do not
have to call get user
because the user handling is done server
side right
so i get this
and
i actually just
altered it a bit here it shouldn't
return text
and i need to unconditionally set
request header x
do you remember the evil kitten
protection x c serve
and i need to set it to one
and then send
and then when i call the apis i had two
apis the goal api
is only accessible when you are signed
in the weather api is accessible both in
a public version and a non-public
version
so the public version returns today's
forecast but not tomorrow's and when we
are logged in we get both
so here i simply can check if if user
not equal null if i have a user
then i can
go ahead and call
the api
the api is of course now on the lo
[Music]
remember i mapped this slash api slash
gold
and i can call
similar way the weather api
should be called always regardless if
the user is signed on or not
and is also in the slash api slash
weather
renew is gone
you know this excellent user interface
with sign out where i signed out of the
identity server and it magically
found out i was signed out and signed
out to the application right away
that is doable with the bff pattern as
well if we have server-side sessions
if we have a database storing the
sessions
and if anyone has an idea how i can
squeeze in a database in the 13 minutes
i have remaining of this talk
please please feel free i don't have an
idea of that so i'm sorry about i'm just
dropping that part of of the
functionality for this demo
so that's it um
that was a lot of code to write which
means how
any any guess on how many bugs i have
before this actually runs and works
i guess there's at least
two
login button
i was logged in already obviously okay
alice alice
welcome alice smith
all apis
goal for today is a 401
okay
i did something i've missed something uh
you see the weather forecast sunny and
nice tomorrow's forecast is only
available for logged in users
so i can call the apis on the remote api
host they are proxied correctly but
apparently i forgot something
to tell the bff to include access tokens
so let's go back and have a look what i
forgot
[Music]
it's in this spa
when i mapped the remote endpoints
i should um
tell it that it needs
and i have a cheat sheet with the
uh require access token require access
token
i
uh need to supply an access token and in
this case
i have a smart fold by thing i want to
use here which is user or client what
this means
is that whenever
the
bff routes an api call to the back
api host behind
it will always include
an access token
if there is a logged in user there will
be an access token so the api is called
on behalf of the logged in user
if there is no user signed in there will
be a client credentials token
authorizing the bff to the api
the good thing about that is that in the
next step we can actually look down our
api so it's the api is no longer
callable directly from the internet
see if this works better this time
you can call the apis
okay um
let's see we go here we call the apis
first weather forecast 401
no no no the api is not happy with us
how come the api is not happy with us
we have the right authority
and we have the
let's log in and see if we can get
through
i have an idea what i might have done
yeah we got when we are signed in we got
it working
when we're signed out
there is i
guess the fault is in the config
that the grant types i set the grant
type to be pure code
and it should of course be code and
client credentials we want our
uh we need to me let's just close this
we need to make sure that our client is
able to request an access token on
behalf of itself when there is no user
signed on
so let's say if i log out
all apis
yes it works
so now the bff goes off fetch is an
access token and an anonymous access
token but still proving that the call
came from the bff
and can call the api
so it works
committed by
three two bugs i guess two
do i get cookies now
i've handed out all my cookies i don't
have any more cookies to hand out
um
but we're not still we're not completely
done yet i want to go to and have a look
at the api
because when we look at the api host
this is the
setup that we accept inbound tokens
then we have the authorization policy to
detect whether we have a login user or
not that is used by the weather forecast
api then we have course crossover gen
resource sharing
do we need that anymore
no we can drop that because course is a
concept for
course is a concept to allow
cross-domain javascript calls and now
we're not doing that anymore we are
calling directly from the bff into the
api
and
we can do one thing more
we can add a require authorization on
the weather the forecast and saying that
even though it's allowed to be
accessible both if you have signed in
user and not
we don't have to
[Music]
allow anonymous access to the api the
api should only be callable by the bff
so we're closing down direct data api
access from the internet
and one more thing
my weather forecast api is a generic api
that a lot of services in my corporation
uses but the gold service is
something that just my html show of
application uses so i'm moving that
simply
to my
bar
and as bff api endpoint i add that
to say that i want this to be
sorry i want this to have the xc serve
requirement
last thing i need to do is site.js
now the google api is available locally
directly right
so i cleaned it up i simplified my
architecture i've secured my api from
direct calls it's only callable through
my bff i have a much clearer view now
who will call it
it still works
yeah it's a sound check for the um
for the the
[Music]
first of
the festival or the concert tonight and
the ndc crew said that if this sound
check started and was disturbing i
should just dance a bit and wait
i'm happy that it's not louder than i
can still talk
uh if i log in
alice alice
i can call the apis and get everything
so
we've taken
our application let's see if i have the
presentation still running somewhere
here
so we've taken our application our
single page application
we have found out that in the new modern
world where browsers are look looking
down locking down
cookies we need this architecture yes
over here
no no i removed it from the from the api
over here so previously before this
transition
the
client-side application called the api
directly and then i would need cores to
allow cross-domain call
but now
the our api is only called by another
server so i can remove the course
yes
and the and the access token is kept on
the bff
the javascript side never gets the
access token
the javascript uses a cookie that is
http only to communicate with the bff so
by keeping the valuable tokens
out of the javascript application
if a request needs to be signed
by the
by tls signing
so if you need to sign sign so that
would essentially be this you would
still have the bff to avoid cross-domain
your javascript should not call
any azure api directly your javascript
should only call your bff running on the
same host
and then you would need to uh
i don't know if you can
use the proxy feature or i would be of
the durand bff
and add request signing
i think it might be possible or you
would have to create a separate api here
that then calls there the next api
yes
whose job is it to keep track of
refreshing tokens so let's see if we can
bring up you remember how long token
lifetime
do you remember what i said i used in
this demo
so
the api the token here let's where are
my mouse
the tokens should definitely be expired
by now
but it still works
this is built into the bff component the
bff components use is the identity modal
library for token management
and the identity mobile library contains
automatic token refreshing
so
when using server side components we can
use the identity mode library that will
keep trying when an access token is
retrieved you get a lifetime back from
the authorization server the identity
model keeps track of that and if the
expiry time has passed it will
automatically use the refresh token to
get a new access token for you so
you never see that part of the
handshakes
the refresh token is something that is
gotten on the original sign in from the
authorization server i do get the
refresh token
yes at the back
uh so the the access token refresh token
where are they actually stored
that is a good question and i'm feeling
like it jumped you know i did a two-day
workshop of these concepts and i feel
like i kind of jumped over one day 1.8
of the day
and just kept this part uh so
the short answer is that they are in the
cookie and the cook is encrypted with
data protection and is a key that is
only available to the bff so even if
it's in the cookie there is no way for
the browser to
read it and use it and besides the
cookie is also http only so any evil
javascript
will not be able to read the cookie
if it is a good good
the question if i got it it's a bit hard
to hear it but if i got it right it was
is would it be a good idea to store the
tokens in a database or regis cache
yes you should do that
because then you get server-side
sessions and then you can do server-side
you can evaluate the fresh check you can
you should revoke the token sign out
there are more things to this especially
on the logout side that i simply don't
have time to show you right now
so one final question here
nearly uh so i'll repeat the question
uh
so this is the handshake that happens
the server redirects the user to the
uh authorization server
sorry i should maybe have this slide
instead it's the pixie flow so the so
there is a front channel redirect back
and forth happening first
what is actually passing over the
browser is only the authorization code
it's an identifier representing the
authentication happening
and then there is a back channel called
directly from the server side to the sds
to retrieve the tokens
the tokens are never exposed in the
browser yes so
if we look at this the the tokens are
all the token handshakes are happening
entirely on a back channel you just get
this authorization code
it's a one-time thing and also proof key
code exchange
contains a code verifier that means that
the server has a one-time secret that is
needed to be able to retrieve the token
on the first time so even if you steal
the code if or i steal the code
i cannot exchange it in any way
because i need the code verifier that
only the initiating server has
so i'm sorry but
i think we are running out of time
aren't we
and i guess i have another speaker that
will be upset so i'll be available if i
continue i will be available outside for
any more questions but thank you so much
for having me and enjoy your cookies